okay thank you Alistair so first of all
let me say it's a an honor and a
privilege and a real pleasure to come
and contribute to Dix it's a celebration
of dicks
80th birthday dick has influenced my
research enormous Lee I have sort of
made a career in some sense out of
taking some of his papers and working on
them and impotent trying to sort of
improve some of the staff I I remember
the carp sips algorithm I must have
written ten papers on the on the carp
sips around gorilla and on his patching
algorithm for TSP I've made a sort of
career out of that and he will be
surprised to hear that his constructive
version of walk-ups bipartite matching
algorithm was vital for the proof that
two in two out is whatever that means
that two into out is a hamiltonian with
high probability so why I know the other
thing I was thinking is that while
Dick's work is characterized by elegance
and simplicity mine is characterized by
brute force and ignorance I think so my
talk will be about something which goes
back to Dick's early work on the
probabilistic analysis algorithm and
that is the the unit square which is
quite an interesting place the unit
square so I realized that lunch is soon
so don't worry I will finish whatever
happens I will finish so this is joint
work with Wesley penguin
he's a column colleague at Carnegie
Mellon okay so here is the playground
the dots represent two random points and
where we basically basically interested
in the length of the shortest tour
through these point
okay call that Z there's a classical
theorem beardwood Hopeton and Hamersley
of God knows when we prove that with
high probability of probability 1 Z
divided by square root n tends to some
constant beta TSP and this is a very old
paper 60 years and we still really don't
know what this constant it's sort of
hidden from us and an interesting there
isn't as far as I know there's no
explanation why well I don't know I
haven't seen an explanation why we don't
know what the constant is that might be
something of interest of course the
beard with the b8h result is more
general than this thing a lot more
general distributions and they also do D
dimensions but this is the basic result
I know they said price value okay so now
we're going to consider a variation on
this in which so you can think of
putting endpoints uniform in the random
Square and then considering the
distances between them as a random
embedding of the complete graph and then
and then assigning the corresponding
Euclidean weights so naturally when you
think about that if you talk about that
you think why just embed the complete
graph think of another graph twin bed
and so we are thinking about embedding
GNP or our random graph so what you have
is you throw the yen points uniformly
around that means the unit Square and
sum plus and then you're going to go
around and find our Hamilton cycle or
minimum length tour but some edges are
not allowed some you're not allowed to
go from itj and you're not allowed to
try PJ with probability 1 minus P and
there are some we did some some results
on that so we considered first of all
how does this affect so if P is very
small then the graph is very sparse and
what it does is it makes it hard to
forget from A to B and we analyzed that
up to a certain point
so you can see there's a lot of symbols
there I'll just say P is small it's very
different to the Euclidian thing if P is
reasonably large it looks like the
Euclidian thing and there's a picture
okay so on the left you have small p on
the left and larger p on the right and
we sort of got it up to about a log log
n squared factor but I don't want to and
the proof is brute force first moment
method for the first case low P and this
is all about jumping from giant
component to giant component and I see
right let's go on and the next point is
what happens to the Traveling Salesman
problem so we know that if P is 1 which
is the normal case that the length of
the tour is beta times square root n so
the question should be for GNP R it
should be beta P times the square root
in that's what you would expect that the
beads which would change the routine
won't change but the beta will just be
now a function of P and so we were able
to we were not able to prove that in any
Wow
we could prove that if P is constant
then there is a beta P okay it's not
completely well you know it does require
work but we could not prove that when P
goes to 0 and the problem with air is
that the usual method is some sort of
what they could you just partition it
and you use subadditivity and the
problem is when you look at the little
squares when P goes to 0 you've got a
different P now relative to the size of
the thing whereas if P is constant P is
constant and you can push everything
through I mean you come up against some
small roadblocks but you can put it
through so making progress so now I'd
like to talk about these things called
which we call Euclidean functionals okay
so after the beard would halt and
hammers the result and
paper on partitioning on the algorithm
happy to meet you looked at the proof
I'm guessing he looked at the proof of
and saw that you could push it through
for matches and so he proved that for
the perfect matching problem in the unit
square or the D cube there's a beta and
it's the same beta time screwed in and
we'll call that one beta perfect
matching then after that still
generalize the bhh theorem and show that
it was that this routine times beta is
sort of I don't know what the word is a
paradigm or phenomenon that there are
things called Euclidean functionals so
for the minimum spanning tree there's a
beta MST and for the minimum length to
factor and often there's a beta to
factor and then a quite a difficult
paper Komen's or Homans and bet CMAs
showed that if you consider the held car
or the linear programming relaxes a the
natural linear programming relaxation of
the TSP that there is a beta HK okay and
none of these constants are known a lot
of mean not to me anyway as far as I
know and if anybody comes and tells me
now this is the end of the talk so these
are constraints are not known and they
could in fact all be the same you could
in fact have b2 MST equal B 2 TSP or the
B 2 TSP could be twice the perfect
matching or the hell compound could be
asymptotically optimal it could be but
yeah sure what's up
did you know the MST one okay good okay
well that's the end of the talk then
okay so let's continue let's get so we
could we have some refinement so MST big
Delta will be denote the minimum length
of a spanning tree if we put a bound on
the maximum degree so MST two would be a
will be a Hamilton path and to factor G
will be no it will be the to factor
problem where you put a lower band on
the girth so every cycling the two
factors will have to be at least G and
it will skip the HF it's not terribly
interesting and all these are functions
have their own beaters okay so the news
is that they are different that the TSP
which is the minimum spanning tree two
is strictly bigger than minimum spanning
tree three it's is strictly bigger and
it doesn't go on forever it goes on to
the some point when you know that in the
minimum spanning tree the maximum degree
is bounded so for liking the unit square
you never the minimum spanning tree has
maximum degree six it's something called
the kissing number the next thing we
proved was that so where's and I was
that the so if you put girth three
that's just your that's just just your
standard to factor but if you if you say
it's going to be at least four then it
goes up so be to the two factor three is
that's the be to take the fun so on and
so on and what's nice is that after you
allow the girth to go to infinity then
the limit is the actual TSP and
unfortunately offer doesn't matter
really
the held Karp bound is beatta for that
is strictly smaller than the TSP
actually what we we show they're
different but just different so if you
actually if we never even we don't even
we do not even say in the paper that we
do not try to optimize we just leave it
at that because if you actually look at
the difference is I have no clue I if I
should say that there were ten to the
minus a hundred difference between the
two I think I probably lying these that
the proofs really yeah so you will not
notice the difference you know in the
current universe right and slightly
bigger universe you might not in this
one and matching so they're all
different okay and what's the next thing
oh yes and then as an application sort
of an unfortunate negative thing about
this is that if you were to use just the
held cart bound for your branch and
bound algorithm then with high
probability it takes almost exponential
time you have to do a lot of branching
to actually and this is even if I give
you the I tell you what the minimum
length tour is and I just asked you to
approve it but that's the minimum length
tour and it just takes exponential
almost exponential time okay so the
proofs are actually not too well let's
say they're simple the gadget they're
just basically by gadget okay so the
idea is that because we've got a large
number of points all right we have a
linear number of little configurations
so here let me see what do we here we
have four points let's do this one right
yeah so we have a linear number of
places inside the square which consists
of
basically you see little set of points
here and it's sort of separated from the
rest so everything that happens here you
sort of independent of the rest okay
and what you would like to do in this
situation if you see you like the top
row because you're saying the maximum
degrees - you're forced to do something
silly your force for your tree to do the
thing at the top make a par whereas
really you would like to take the little
tree which has a vertex of degree three
and every time you do that you'll pay
some small cuts like small a really
small constant divided by the square
root of n so every time you do that and
this happens with high probability end
times order n times so you pay and so
that's it and then for every other for
every other thing there's a different
gadget and the gadgets get more and more
complicated as you consider longer
complicated functions so let's see on
this and there are all sorts of things
you have to do you have to sort of make
sure that you can't cheat by coming in
to this thing only going through half
the gadget and then going down again you
have to argue that that won't save you
so that takes some more work and here's
the same thing with the factors you have
to do things like this and then with the
factors now now we can see why the
contents are getting really small okay
so with the factors we have these
gadgets which we would like really to
have four cycles but we're not allowed
done and then we do something and if
we're not careful we will create four
cycles so what we have to do surround
our gadgets by this cloud of points very
close together and somehow we can use
that to force us to to show that in fact
we're
that we okay so we do this gadget we
make this change then oh my god what
we've done is we've created some small
cycles but we need these big clouds of
points outside which will turn these
small cycles in the bigger ones at a
very small cost and we use Dix patching
idea throughout the paper and then the
branch and bound we just argue that the
branch and bound tree actually it was
yeah so the the natural thing to do
would be so what's the branch and bound
algorithm so you build this tree and
every and every vertex has some num some
sets associated with it it's got those
things which IV which is the edges you
forced in and Ovie the edges you forced
out and a lower bound and the lower
bound run and what we basically argue is
that if if LV and OVR small then your
two factor bound or your sort of your
lower bound which is currently bit low
it started out bigger than the tsp it
may shrink a bit like it's go up sorry
it still good the lower bound will go up
oh yeah the lower bound will go up but
it doesn't reach the tour the tour
length okay unless LV and OVR large and
even there there was a small problem
which we had to instead of dealing with
all the tours we just dealt with the
sort of Tours that dicks out rhythm
delphine okay so that took exponential
time and this is taking polynomial time
this is good and then the 88 well forget
that right so then for just for the last
five minutes so this is an idea that
Waverly thought up so
here's a claim okay so so for there we
were looking at so we looking at
branch-and-bound
right and we're saying that if I give
you the upper bound if I give you the
minimum length of the tour but you don't
have a good lower bound then things are
bad so the opposite would be I give you
a great lower bound which is correct but
I don't give you an algorithm so you
need to have some heuristic which is
finding tours to compare with that okay
so there are certain sorts of algorithms
so like well nearest Nate let's consider
nearest neighbor so the point is when
nearest neighbor meets these gadget
places you can sort of argue that either
if that's an excu
or it tends to just do it go through the
nearest neighbor through the gadget so
it's like being nearest neighbor on the
gadget okay and it has to do this lots
of times a linear number of time so it's
like nearest neighbor on the gadget what
does this mean well so if we use
Christy's np-hardness proof so you start
off with vertex cover and so inside this
big mass of endpoints there will be
zillions of what we call P sets all
right and some of these will be yeah and
so and this algorithm it's like the
nearest neighbor algorithm cannot get it
right all the time because heavey and
custard yeah eventually they eventually
these peach sets get bigger and bigger
for a large and largest size and they
must make mistakes otherwise they would
solve vertex cover and so this is a sort
of proof that near isn't I mean you
could probably come up with another
proof that nearest neighbor didn't give
you a beta route in but this one sort of
tells you that nearest neighbor doesn't
give you a beetroot in and actually we
can sort of put it in to us or a large
of heuristics which Wesley calls
scale-free and the remainder it's not
quite that simple because there's all
sorts of talk about the issue of
rounding how many bits do you need and
stuff like that which makes the
definition a bit ugly but that's quite
nice and the only thing that's well not
the only oh yes two things to say says
first of all op k opt is product
probably well we think it's in the class
what we can't prove it and Dick's
algorithm is not in the class because
that uses exponential time on the little
squares so sticks not Dickies not
scale-free I'm not sure if that's good
or bad but yet I thought about yet and
here's a picture of Chris Darcy's
picture and I can finish oh yeah and
then so you can do some sort of
primitive branch-and-bound and say
something bad about that so there's some
open questions nothing's very
interesting there's a few of these
things which we don't know I get that
all right thank you very much
oh that's not it's good
so the there's your paper right and for
gin for the further what we call Chi NP
we don't know whether your algorithm
still works you may know but I we don't
know for the here isn't to get well for
P constant we can use thick cloud rhythm
but for what's it called for P going to
0 well first what we don't know whether
your algorithm works and for P Guayana 0
you can still you can get I can't
remember to be honest this is a year ago
you think your admin should work yeah
did you okay okay
really Wow two three uh-huh
tell me when I was an Omega
that was some arbitrary function which
tends to infinity its J is just that
week we yeah we can it should be log D
to the N over N oh my god
well I'll make it a D and Omega the
basically the same sort of thing right
and so the log log shouldn't be there
it's just a proof bit of the proof the
log log shouldn't be there
well I don't know but I assume they
shouldn't be there right okay so Omega
and this one is this this papers on the
the first two papers are on the way on
my home page if you're interested in
reading them